one man in the UK has 8 000 Bitcoin on a
hard drive but he can't find it and now
he has a wild insane plan on how to
recover it James Howells is a former I.T
worker he had those 8 000 Bitcoin on a
hard drive that he accidentally threw
out in 2013. he knows which landfill in
the UK the hard drive went to but he
hasn't been able to actually locate it
and now he's got this crazy plant he
wants to raise 11 million dollars from
Venture capitalists to go ahead pick up
all that trash sift through it using
humans and artificial intelligence as if
that wasn't enough Powell's also wants
to buy two Boston Dynamic robot dogs to
go around the facility trying to locate
the hard drive with 176 million dollars
of Bitcoin on the current plan would
take three years to dig through the 110
000 tons of trash and there's no promise
that I'll actually find the Bitcoin the
plan also calls for eight experts in
artificial intelligence excavation waste
management and data extraction if
successful James Howells will get 176
million dollars of Bitcoin those 8 000
Bitcoins will be back in his hand but
he'll have to have paid his staff all
the equipment and not to pay back the
investor let me know in the comments
whether you think he's gonna find the
Bitcoin or not it'll be a crazy crazy
story if he does